[Musique]
bonjour alexis je
gravis vous retrouver dans la matinale
berthet france alors agnès buzyn a été
mise en examen par la cour de justice de
la république
selon vous quel quelles sont les suites
de ce dossier
alors déjà il va y avoir peut-être
d'autres ministres et le premier
ministre un edouard philippe à l'époque
qui vont aussi devoir passer devant
cette cour de justice de la république
puisque rappelez vous les gérants comme
edouard philippe comme à nice +1 avait
aussi été perquisitionné dans le cadre
de ces enquêtes il y à de nombreuses
plaintes également déposée contre donc
la suite c'est peut-être savoir ce qu'il
s'est passé dans cette gestion
calamiteuse de crise cent vingt mille
morts les masques qui n'étaient pas là
les stocks de masques et est moisi les
soignants piotet envoyé au front sans
équipement de protection les mensonges à
répétition bien entendu et est une vraie
question pourquoi une telle gestion de
crise sans préparation finalement sans
avoir jamais cette capacité de prévoir
alors sur un lob puisque usées qu' on ne
pouvait pas savoir à l'époque or c'est
faux il avait de nombreux médecins qui
alertait ch les services spéciaux
français également dès le mois de
décembre et janvier parler de ce virus
chinois et agnès buzyn quand elle part
d'ailleurs du ministère de la santé pour
faire campagne à paris rappelez-vous
elton cette interview qui avait fait
couler beaucoup d'encre dans le monde où
elle dit je savais que c'était le pire
qui nous attendait et néanmoins je
devais partir donc il y a beaucoup de
questions en suspens et on espère que
via la cour de justice de la république
les français auront des réponses puisque
pour une fois la commission d' enquête
qui a été menée par la majorité la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale a fait tout pour enterrer une
enquête responsables et l'ong sur les
responsabilités des ministres lors du
début de cette crise alors alexis est ce
qu'on peut parler comme certains membres
de la majorité un
d'instrumentalisation de la justice
alors non déjà il n'y a pas que les
membres de la majorité on voit bien
qu'il ya toute la classe politique un
key qui a peur dès que l'un des leurs se
retrouve sous l'oeil des juges il y a
laurent berger par exemple de la cfdt
qui lui parle même de de scandale
démocratique un de perversion de la
démocratie donc ça va très loin il n'en
est rien la cour de justice de la
république il faut le rappeler c'est une
juridiction d'exception qui a été
critiqué pour ça françois hollande ne
voulait d'ailleurs là la supprimer lors
de son mandat il ne l'a pas fait on voit
que tous les ministres qui sont passés
par cette cour de justice qui est la
seule habilitée à les juger pendant
les choses qu'ils ont pu faire pendant
leurs fonctions n'ont jamais été
lourdement condamné un que ce soit à
charles pasqua ce soit laurent fabius
georgina dufoix tous ceux qui étaient
dans le scandale du sang contaminé n'ont
pas été réellement condamnés donc il ya
beaucoup de critiques par rapport à
cette cour de justice de la république
qui est qui donne finalement le
sentiment citoyen français qu' il ya une
justice à deux vitesses celle pour les
riches ils pour les puissants scène pour
une qui gouverne et puis celle pour les
autres en parallèle de sa par exemple il
faut voir que le parquet de paris a
classé sans suite plus de 16 mille
plaintes contre les effets secondaires
du vaccin et contre les effets également
du port du masque pour les enfants donc
circulez ya rien à voir donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une justice qui n'est pas
finalisé mais qui néanmoins ne va
peut-être pas faire ce qu'il faut faire
certains avocats s'étonnent de la
rapidité avec laquelle la cour de
justice de la république réa j ai
préféré que ce soient les juridictions
pénales qui elle se met également à
travailler sur cette question ducobu et
néanmoins alexis est ce que cela ne
pourrait pas être un caillou dans la
chaussure pour emmanuel macron qui n'est
pas encore déclaré néanmoins pour 2022
alors clairement c'est un énorme couac
dans la communication gouvernementale et
particulièrement celle des malaises
mâcon qui est encore pas une permanente
emmanuel macron c'est quand même celui
qui s'enorgueillit d'être le meilleur
gestionnaire de cette crise sanitaire
ducobu des meilleurs épidémiologistes
selon ses proches un qui était capable
de lire en anglais les dernières revues
médicales pour savoir quoi faire et on
voit bien qu'avec cette convocation
d'agnès b dans cette mise en examen est
bien il va y avoir plus de questions qui
vont être posées et on va bien se rendre
compte que le narratif de la majorité du
président de la république est une
réécriture de l'histoire est une
invention pour faire croire que la
gestion était formidable de a à z alors
que ça a été depuis le début une
improvisation sans nom le stop de masse
bien entendu les atermoiements autour de
la chloroquine ensuite la campagne de
tests l'absence de protection pour les
soignants je le disais depuis
aujourd'hui l'obligation vaccinale pour
les soignants en les montrant du doigt
comme étant le problème donc on voit
bien qu'il ya un vrai souci de
transparence les manuels macron qui a
choisi d'ailleurs de tout régler en
conseil de défense sous le sceau du
secret défense pour éviter justement
d'avoir à répondre aux questions de la
justice c'est ça qui va poser problème
évidemment pour le narratif et la
campagne de communication permanente des
malades macron puisque là nous aurons
des questions et il faudra des réponses
merci beaucoup alexis alexis poule a on
peut retrouver votre édito sur les
réseaux sociaux et en attendant on vous
retrouve lundi prochain dans la matinale
[Musique]